all of it
come on no not in one go go on I believe
in you we have to celebrate our victory
vomiting is not celebrated as it is he's
little but he's strong strong enough to
befriend an enemy and get murdered for
it
most people get bloody murdered not this
one here we are now it's one of you
cowards [ __ ] in my pants please pardon
me for a moment
all that this [ __ ] comes north and
takes her from just takes her like that
don't touch me I'm happy I'm happy that
you're happy I'm happy that you'll
finally have to climb further do you
know how long I've waited to tell tall
person jokes to climbing mountains to
climbing mountains the pair of tall
blond Tufts must be like looking in the
mirror the Brawn of the black water you
boys are a pair of gold-plated const you
know that that's a bit rude year after
year and I've shoveled Lannister [ __ ]
what do I have to show you're a knight
thanks to me thanks to me and that tie
it was worth as much as a blunder from
your brother's boss shut your mouth
[Music]
you're not gonna ride the dragon south
Greg Earl needs to heal he doesn't need
me wearing him down you weigh as much as
two fleas [ __ ] I'm taking the free
folk home we've had enough of the south
this is the north you know it's where he
belongs to the dog wolf has no place in
the south will you take him with you
[Applause]
how did they find you did you consider
taking it off
Cersei once called me the stupidest
Lannister when have I ever been able to
convince you of anything
joy if not for yourself if not forever
and for every one of the million people
in that city innocent or otherwise to be
honest I never really cared much for
them innocent or otherwise you know King
oh but I am and I [ __ ] the Queen
[Applause]
so Gregor I could mount you the Bayeux
Queen said Gregor
[Applause]
[Music]
and I'd like to think my experience has
led to some small skill in statecraft
and Custer please sit
[Laughter]
maybe the decision about what's best for
everyone should be left to everyone
[Laughter]
there's nothing in the world more
powerful than a good story nothing can
stop it and who has a better story than
brand the broken do you wear the crown
will you lead the seven kingdoms to the
best of your abilities from this day
until your last day why do you think I
came all this way
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's this a Song of Ice and Fire
I suppose I come in for some heavy
criticism oh I wouldn't say that he's
kind to me I don't believe you mentioned
and drogon any word he was last spotted
flying east rather long waited the
better
perhaps I can find him to carry on with
the rest
Capote wreck long may he reign long may
he reign on me long may he reign long
may he reign that will improve I'm sure
it will all the best brothels burned out
the master of coin is willing to fund
reconstruction the archmaester is less
than enthusiastic about the salutary
effects of brothels I imagine he isn't
using them properly I think you can
agree that ships take precedence over
brothels I think that's a very
presumptuous statement
[Music]
[Applause]